good afternoon i'm captain carlos hank
the las vegas metropolitan police
department office of maternal oversight
i'm here today to brief you on the
officer-involved shooting eighth
officer-involved shooting in lvnpd's
jurisdiction
on today october 12th at approximately
9 00 a.m officers responded to the 5600
block of east lake mead reference a
shots fired call
upon their arrival they determined that
a suspect had kidnapped his
ex-girlfriend
and had fled the area while possessing a
firearm
through their investigation officers
tracked the suspect and the victim and
located him here in the area of
charleston and sloan
the officers attempted to de-escalate
the situation and get the suspect to
release the female
ultimately the suspect pointed his
firearm at officers and officers
discharged their firearm striking the
suspect
during this time the suspect the female
was rescued by officers
the officers responded to the suspect
and rendered aid
ultimately the suspect died on scene
these are the preliminary details
a member of executive staff will come
before you within 72 hours and provide
additional details thank you
can we just get some clarification none
of the businesses here were involved so
the albertsons
and angelina
they didn't actually go in there
this is a very large complex crime scene
it's very uh preliminary right now we
have it uh shut down just to make sure
that we're thorough and we collect any
and all evidence involved in the
investigation how are the officers
involved doing right now the officers
are doing fine
any details about age or any suspect
descriptions i don't have an age for you
at this time approximate
young old
middle age uh
excuse me i do not have an age for you
this time
do you believe that the hostages life
was in danger